[Music]
nothing is more active than thought for
it travels over the universe and nothing
is stronger than necessity for all must
submit to
it nothing exists except atoms and empty
space everything else is just
[Music]
opinion it is hard to contend against
one's heart's desire for whatever it
wishes to have it buys at the cost of
the
[Music]
Soul medicine to produce Health must
examine disease and music to create
Harmony must investigate
Discord you shall I question not find a
way to the Top If You diligently seek
for it for nature hath placed nothing so
high that it is Out Of Reach of Industry
and
Valor I am not afraid of an army of
lions led by a sheep I am afraid of an
army of sheep led by a
lion no man ever wetted clay and then
left it as if there would be Bricks by
chance and
[Music]
Fortune he who is of a calm and happy
nature will hardly feel the pressure of
age but to him who is of an opposite
disposition Youth and age are equally a
[Music]
burden I only wish that Ordinary People
had an unlimited capacity for doing harm
then they might have an unlimited power
for doing
[Music]
good the greatest way to live with honor
in this world is to be what we pretend
to
be
the greater the difficulty the more the
glory in surmounting
[Music]
it all human actions have one or more of
these seven causes chance nature
compulsions habit reason passion
[Music]
desire youth is easily deceived because
it is quick to
Hope
the ideal man Bears the accidents of
life with dignity and Grace making the
best of
circumstances the very spring and root
of honesty and virtue lie in good
education worthless people live only to
eat and drink people of worth eat and
drink only to
live
when men speak ill of thee live so as
nobody May believe
them even when laws have been written
down they ought not always to remain
unaltered there are two things a person
should never be angry at what they can
help and what they
cannot apply yourself both now and in
the next life without effort you cannot
be prosperous though the land be good
you cannot have an abundant crop without
cultivation do not say little in many
words but a great deal in
[Music]
few when you want wisdom and insight as
badly as you want to breathe it is then
you shall have
it the One exclusive sign of thorough
knowledge is the power of
[Music]
teaching are you not ashamed of heaping
up the greatest amount of money and
honor and reputation and caring so
little about wisdom and truth and the
greatest Improvement of the
[Music]
soul the learning and knowledge that we
have is at the most but little compared
with that of which we are ignorant
[Music]
one thing I know that I know nothing
this is the source of my
wisdom true wisdom comes to each of us
when we realize how little we understand
about life ourselves and the world
around
us silence at the proper season is
wisdom and better than any
speech
the only true wisdom is in knowing you
know
[Music]
nothing I know that I am intelligent
because I know that I know
nothing but his sister Artemis the wild
the lady of wild beasts scolded him
bitterly and spoke a word of
revilement you run from him Striker from
afar fool then why do you wear that bow
which is wind and
nothing they did not recognize her gods
for Mortals are hard to
[Music]
see her gray eyes clear the goddess
Athena answered down from the skies I
come to check your rage if only you will
yield seeing Oh Muse of the Rage of
Achilles son of pelus that brought
countless ills upon the
aans beauty Terrible Beauty a deathless
goddess so she strikes our
eyes hateful to me as the gates of Hades
is that man who hides one thing in his
heart and speaks
another once we'd left the island in our
wake no land at all in sight nothing but
sea and sky then Zeus the son of cronis
mounted a Thunderhead above our Hollow
ship and the Deep went black beneath
it Athena you wish to be called
righteous rather than act right I say
wrong must not win by
[Music]
technicalities bear up my child bear up
Zeus who oversees and directs all things
is still Mighty in the heaven
those who intend on becoming great
should love neither themselves nor their
own things but only what is just whether
it happens to be done by themselves or
others true love never has a happy
ending because there is no ending to
true
[Music]
love whatever possession we gain by our
sword cannot be sure of lasting but the
love gained by kindness and moderation
is certain and
durable of all the varieties of Virtues
liberalism is the most
[Music]
beloved there are three classes of men
lovers of wisdom lovers of honor and
lovers of
[Music]
gain one word frees us of all the weight
and pain of life
that word is
[Music]
love selfishness doesn't consist in a
love of yourself but in a big degree of
such
[Music]
love to love rightly is to love what is
orderly and beautiful in an educated and
disciplined
way love is the joy of The Good The
Wonder of the wise the amazement of the
Gods
love is composed of a single soul
inhabiting two
[Music]
bodies at the touch of love everyone
becomes a
[Music]
poet